so how about this from one class act to
another talking about new basketball
great Kareem abdul-jabbar is shedding
new light on his relationship with one
of the best coaches in basketball
history
legendary UCLA coach says John Wooden
and his 7-foot tall big man lost just
twice during their time together in
Westwood Los Angeles they went on to win
three straight NCAA championships from
1967 through 1969 the Hall of Fame coach
and player remained closed long after
that time on the court they form one of
the most enduring relationships in
sports history Abdul Jabbar's nubuck
coach wooden and me our 50-year
friendship on and off the court gives an
intimate look at their deep bond Kareem
abdul-jabbar welcome back thank you III
knew Coach wooden and and you can't say
enough about him but this is special
because you were a great player and had
this great relationship what was in
essence about him that we all want to
understand appreciate and emulate his
motivation to to coach had to do with
his Christian faith he wanted to use
basketball as a means to have an
influence on young men and show them how
to live their lives but you were become
a Muslim well you know morality is
morality you know it's about right and
wrong it's don't have to be that
specific and when I became Muslim you
know I like coach wouldn't know about it
and he wanted to know what my
motivations were and everything but he
did not disapprove he just wanted to
understand what my thought process was
and where I was coming from as a person
but you write that and talk about being
a person you write that he didn't really
focus on becoming better players he
wanted that too but more importantly was
making better people that seemed to
matter to him above everything that that
was his ultimate goal but into it on the
way to that we want a few basketball
game the night when he focus on you said
you two were an odd couple waiting to
happen he's a y55 from Indiana which
some people say at the time was plan
country yours 18 seven foot two from the
inner city and you said in the beginning
it was mutual respect but not warrants
the mutual bond was basketball but once
I got to know Coach wooden and
understand him and I was English major
he was an English teacher so we had
things to talk about that nothing to do
with sport and he enjoyed that he
enjoyed expanding the relationship and
what it was based on if you write all
the time to quote an X are quoted up all
the time quoting Shakespeare never
sitting here all this favorite his poets
and I was surprised he was into Langston
Hughes and that that really surprised me
you know you write that he echoed a lot
of values that you that you had learned
at home and one of his favorite sayings
was don't hope hope is for people who
aren't prepared exactly we don't need to
know we need to understand what the
problem is and figure out some solutions
and be ready for the problem when it
gets here because it's coming work ethic
yeah work ethic and just preparation was
what it was all about one of his
favorite sayings was failing to prepare
is preparing to fail I love that she
stole from Ben Franklin but it was quite
appropriate do you have the skyhook
before you got to UCLA I started work on
the hook shot when I was in the fifth
grade I had that chance is the greatest
shot ever in basketball I think in fifth
grade skies 11 or something oh no I
wasn't that tall but I think where you
are exact no we're really tall I got to
be 6/8 when I was in the 8th grade going
on 14 one of his other important lessons
I loved it there is that skyhook we
should never focus on the outcome but on
the activity itself how's that guided
you well everybody wants to win
everybody feels best when they're
winning but learning what you need to
learn to win is really the crux of it
you know because you can't win all the
time
no but you you had a pretty good record
you said that you and coach wouldn't
were fluent in basketball but you don't
think players and coaches can have that
kind of relationship that you two had
back then today I don't think that
that's possible now because kids aren't
going to call
now to get an education they're going to
play basketball and move on to the NBA
when it is good so that that's basically
what's happening and it's rare to see
some guys stay and try to get that it
was I was very impressed with University
of Wisconsin the guys stayed they made a
commitment to each other into the school
and they're in the NCAA finals two years
in a row I really admired what they
achieved as students and as athletes for
you for writing this book yeah thank you
creme Abdullah Mara always a pleasure to
have you here thank you so much lesser
be here coach wooden and me goes on sale
tomorrow